all right in this video we are going to
be talking about the timeline tab of
chrome developer tools when there are
performance issues in your webpage this
is a great place to start because it
records everything then you can look in
detail from a whole bunch of different
ways so we're gonna do I'm just gonna
hit this record button I'm going to
refresh the page it is capturing stacks
profiles of the JavaScript memory and
paint which is like CSS so once I do
that I'm gonna press the stop button
okay it downloaded all this
informational to delimit retrieved all
this information it says the largest
part was scripting of all the aggregated
time what's really cool about this is
how many ways
it'll organize the information it just
took it's just in a split second got all
this data and it's gonna organize it for
you invest with it makes sense to you
which i think is awesome so in this view
you can zoom in on specific things it
tells you exactly what's scripting in
this summary if we go down here this
main thread in all these details again
it's color coded each one of these green
line the blue line the red line has to
do with when the document object model
is loaded let's go ahead and switch
views to this way so here this is so
awesome
I'm geeking out right now so I'm still
so excited about it if I click this
first bar which is the biggest one as
somebody who's not I'm not an expert in
Google development tools I'm still
learning and I encourage all of you to
do the same and just get in there play
around click on things see what they
mean if you have a question ask it's the
best way to learn so this main thread
went all the way throughout but here if
we click on this save timeline data load
timeline data it's gonna bring it up in
this lower bar here as well so I'm gonna
make this bigger I won't be able to see
much of the main page anymore back to
the timeline I click this and it brings
up all this information about this one
thing it says the type which is the
value 8 script the total time the self
time the link to the script it'll take
me exactly I'm going to click this where
in the document this is this exact piece
of code so if your page has a
performance issues maybe there's
memories not quite working the way you'd
expect it
to the whole thing's taking a long time
this is a great place to look just to
see exactly where the problem is what
part of it's taking so long
and it you can view that information and
use it so efficiently to fix the problem
quickly and get your page running
smoothly what I want you to take away
from this is not everything you're not
going to be able to get it all at once
get in there and play around with it and
see which way works best for you when
you're looking at all that information
that it has to offer and remember when
you're editing a page and editing the
information for a page it's not going to
save so if you fix a problem in the
browser make sure you keep track of what
you're doing so you can fix it in your
original documents as well